joining me now former packers executive
currently the executive director of the
morad center at villanova he writes for
sports illustrated and his business of
sports pod is must listen to material
certainly this week he is andrew brandt
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you sir
doing well my friend good to be with you
as always same here okay so
lay out for me what you think is playing
out in green bay
right now
andrew
take you back a little bit because i did
think there was no credence to
2021
aaron rodgers not being in green bay
he was not going to retire the packers
were not going to trade him the packers
weren't ready to promote jordan love and
they wanted aaron rodgers mvp abilities
while he keeps the seat warm for the
future
and i think what
drove some of his unsatisfaction last
year in the off season was he wanted to
know the plan like are we moving on to
love next year what's the plan how are
we going to do this if we're moving on
why not do it now all those kind of
things
now we get to the end of 2021 and we're
in that 2022 phase
rich i've always thought since draft day
2020 when they picked jordan love that
this would be the transition
i know aaron sat for three years i know
that's what jordan love could do as well
but i just felt like two years and in
this day and age first round
quarterbacks hardly even sit three games
like long three years
so i just think and i'm not going to
change my mind i think this has been the
packers plan
for two years to move to love in 2022
you combine that
with the fact that aaron's been very
reflective
and
had some issues with the team last year
i know some of that's been cleaned up
but i just think
you know i think it's time
i think both sides
are going to part with each other i
don't know if that's retirement or trade
we can talk more about that but
i just think this is moving a different
direction
so i i guess
you know i i i hear all of that but
rogers keeps getting better
and i know that the results got worse
with rogers getting better this year
that they didn't even make the nfc
championship game
this time around
um but i i i think you know all of that
can be thrown together with circumstance
and a red hot team that came in to one
and done them as opposed to this roster
can't work so
let's walk through just at least this
part
rogers returns what's the cap
looking like right now let's just say
roger says you know what i have
reflected you know what
you know i i i can
stay here longer than any green bay
quarterback ever has
i love devonte i love my home i love my
golf club you know whatever and he
decides you know after all of this i do
want to come back
and they sit there and decide well you
know aaron sat for three years jordan
can too walk me through what that looks
like first before we move on and turn
this well you're talking to the guy who
managed the cavs
i know and
they're a very well managed cap at least
as far as i've known before me after me
i just think that
let's be real cat problems are sometimes
put out there
for reasons and you have a coach that
handles the team you have a general
manager that handles the draft and
bringing in talent
and you have a cap manager that handles
that and the good teams get those things
done
i just think listen the packers are
draft and develop team they have
probably half their roster
on rookie contracts i don't i think
there are ways to manage the cap for the
green bay packers
that people are all up in arms like what
are they going to do go get it done if
they want
the bigger issue is you said rick rich
and
you're talking to a charter member of
the rogers fan club he's playing great
he's the mvp again two years in a row
i just think the packers have to decide
what you're suggesting
does turn out to be a lame duck
situation again
so i just think they have to decide
now it's not going to be three years
till love it's going to be maybe four
years till love because
what's in it for aaron right what's in
it for aaron to be the lame duck in 2022
and
maybe this was the lame duck here we'll
find out soon
but i just think the packers have to
can't have their cake and needed to
anymore they have to make a commitment
to aaron that binds him to the team i
think more than 2022
or they have to move to love that's just
my feeling
and so when you say the cap can be
worked out the whole conversation of uh
adams and rogers and you know whatever
else they may have put on the credit
card um
that that you're not concerned about
that you think i think there's probably
to quote a phrase there's some fat on
the roster that they could trim
there's a franchise tag in play for
adams there's if roger stays everyone
knows what you can do with these big
contracts
bonus out the salary push out the money
attackers as i know so well have been
reticent to do a lot of push out but
this would be a situation that would
warrant that andrew brant former nfl
executive with the packers and as you
pointed out a long time uh capologist
for green bay right here on the rich
eisen show okay so now you you mentioned
the other options for aaron rodgers you
mentioned the retirement word i
do you really think he would retire i
mean
honestly you know jeopardy's not a not a
possibility i mean he doesn't have the
the uh you know um production companies
that brady has right i mean i i mean
obviously he can find whatever he wants
to do but
he's playing he's not even 40 yet and we
just saw brady
do what he did at 44.
so
yeah i get it rich i just think
you know if you've listened to him the
past year and i know everyone will jump
on a lot of the things he said i'm not
talking about that
i'm talking about just the reflective
nature that he's been talking about
these past few weeks and months
and even in his comments the other day
after the game
it seemed less about whether i want to
be with the packers as opposed to a new
team
as to whether i want to keep playing and
listen i get it he's at the top of his
game
and why wouldn't he why wouldn't he not
want to keep playing of course everybody
would want to keep playing at the top of
the game top of the league
but i just recently zen about him i
haven't talked to him i don't know this
i just sense this kind of serene nature
like
savoring every moment savoring walking
out of lambeau savoring this
that this is an option that this is on
the table
so and when the packers say we want them
back
i don't think they're saying
we're not going to trade them
i think they're saying we hope he comes
back like comes back
so
these are all things in play and we're
going to find out hopefully pretty soon
okay so let's just say
there is a parting of the ways let's
make people smarter of what to look for
and how it's going to work and what the
mechanics are of something like that
what what happened trade or retirement
trade
honestly honestly i don't think he's
retiring the guy's too damn good he's
too damn good and i think he does
like you know you
mentioned you said you know you're not
talking about what quote unquote other
stuff i i i it looks like he clearly
does relish having platforms to say
whatever is on his mind
um you know even though uh he's not
being fact-checked in real time a lot
you know so i i think he enjoys
everything that's going on right now
and he's so damn good like he he's so
good and you saw what brady was able to
do and he could choose the peyton
manning option you know
um
[Music]
so to to to ride off into the sunset i
mean
so how does the trade work what do you
think well the best the best thing the
packers did in getting him back last
year was they gave him an out and i
thought maybe to get him back they'd
have to give him an out in 2022
meaning he'd be free to sign anywhere
packers get nothing they gave him an out
in 2023 which means they can trade him
this year and get a bounty so
if that's the move
you know
you've just said it how good he is
i don't know if there's been a bigger
trade in terms of
compensation back but you can look at
this like oh my god the packers played
this immensely well they got two years
of mvp play and now look what they're
getting and as to what they're getting
yeah just throw it all in there get
right like a couple to two to three ones
uh good young players
in the mix i mean how many teams are
going to be bidding for aaron rodgers
but doesn't mean creates leverage and
leverage creates good packages what
about but doesn't aaron have to also be
part of where where he winds up right
yeah
so that was part of the language it was
soft language not written right when he
came back he got the out in 2023 in this
loose language about you know being part
of the team part of the decision in 2022
and then people can start connecting the
dots if nathaniel hackett gets the
denver job i mean these are all
speculation of course but
there are things out there
yeah
so okay
how does it work they sit down and
decide this is you know where roger says
i'm not coming back because the packers
did say you know i mean you heard what
matt lafleur said he said that he thinks
it's going to be different this
offseason around because the
communication is terrific
rogers essentially said i'll make this
decision before free agency you know
whereas last year it was so open-ended
it went all the way to the minute
training camp uh hit
so you know how how crystal ball it for
me you know
did you think that this is it for that
they're gonna have to you know part ways
that you think that this has always been
the plan for green bay which rogers saw
coming you know the minute he was having
his drink on draft night in 2020 and and
and found uh found it within himself to
stay put for two years where he he could
feel comfortable doing it so walk me
through how this does work what the
mechanics are if they do in fact part
ways and he wants to keep playing as he
as he should what do you think matt
lafleur said he had a long conversation
yesterday
or monday
and
i really would love to be a fly on the
wall because if i'm if i'm representing
aaron yeah i'm saying what's the plan
now
well we want aaron back when like for
how long you want to lane when do you
want to go to jordan well you know
because they don't want to answer that
question
and
i think aaron's got to know the plan
and this puts a lot of pressure on the
packers
you know forget cap
we'll work around the cap right we're
going to commit to you more than 2022
i mean again taking away the retirement
question
if that's the case i can see him staying
but if the case is hey
we got to go to jordan and you waited
three years let's just you know well
let's just play this year out i don't
know if aaron rodgers wants that
so
then the decision is all right let's
find a home and if we get to that
then aaron's very involved and what
about denver and what about this team
and what about that team do the right
thing by aaron get the best package
you know all those things come into play
but i continue to get back to the
question is
this was the question a year ago
you take a first round quarterback he's
going to play he's not going to be
flipped he's not going to back up
forever he's going to play hell even
johnny manziel played
so
when is jordan love going to play i
dealt with this for three years 15 years
ago
where aaron's camp was saying is he ever
going to play
and brett's camp was saying
i don't like coming to work every day
and sitting with my replacement
so
this is a lot to manage and the packers
have to decide
how much they want to go through this
isn't also
you know back you mentioned andrew brant
long time executive in the league with
the packers here in the rich island show
you mentioned the two camps back in the
day of farv's camp and rogers camp
aren't they the same camp now aren't
they both quarterbacks represented by
the same agent our friend david dunn
isn't that the case actually they are
yeah so i mean this is complicated but
aaron's as you know as people know
aaron's got caa very involved with his
camp as well
even though david has been doing the
contract
so yeah there are a lot of parties
involved
what's good coons thinking right now do
you think
you know i keep going to that image rich
april you know the the pandemic draft
everyone's in their home and basement
with their kids
uh i keep going to that image of a
smiling bride brian goodkins and a
smiling mat le floor
they traded up for jordan love
so
i get it
you got the best player in the league on
your team but what's the plan there i
don't think they want to waste that
draft pick
i don't
i know good accounts comes from the ted
thompson disciple of
you know live and dive by your draft
picks so
i think it's just fascinating that we
have these two forces right now and
if again i keep getting back to my
premise aaron's got to know the plan and
the plan is all in on aaron great
the plan is let's just run it back a
year and then jordan i don't know if he
wants that doesn't he get the brady out
if that happens you know because we
mentioned that you know we mentioned you
just i guess to bring this all full
circle we mentioned the you know at
least i did the peyton manning plan
right which is you know go to denver and
ride off into the sunset with your
championship there
um
but the brady plan is you get to go
wherever you want
so wouldn't he get to do that if he
stays one more year
right
right
right i mean and that's the contract but
i get back to the loose language about
2022 right
does he want that
does he want you know again
to wait a year to do that when he can do
it now i think if he tells them that's
what he wants to do and they can move to
love which getting back to our start
that i think was the plan in 2020 to
begin with okay so then crystal ball it
for me best you can trust me we'll have
you back we'll check your work what do
you think
i think he's traded
okay and that happens when right around
whenever and then it becomes official
mark middle of march right correct and i
think he's a big part of
the the decision
and where it goes
i i think it's a mutual decision to move
on from aaron yes
well everybody uh go listen to the
businesses sports podcast because you
talk about all this stuff even more in
depth this week and uh we'll have you
back on andrew thanks for the time
always a pleasure rich you got it andrew
brent on twitter i follow him you should
as well right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here